bring in michigan republican
representative peter meyer who serves on
the house foreign affairs committee
congressman meyer is also an iraq war
veteran and just returned
from afghanistan congressman thank you
so much for joining us want to talk
about how this trip came to be you
traveled there with congressman seth
moulton from massachusetts how did it
come to pass
thank you brett both seth and myself
have been actively engaged on what's
called the special immigrant visa issue
those were visas and a program for
individuals who would loyally serve the
united states in places like iraq and
afghanistan there have been a tremendous
backlog of these cases and in april when
president biden announced that he was
continuing the initial plan for
withdrawal that started under president
trump
we urged the administration to address
this backlog we had to know what was
going on on the ground in kabul and we
have not had information we need from
the administration
and realized that we were being lied to
up and down and we needed to see for
ourselves
so
carson moulton tweeted out today with
representative meyer i visited kabul
airport to conduct oversight on the
evacuation witnessing our young marines
and soldiers at the gates navigating a
confluence of humanity as raw and
visceral as the world has ever seen was
indescribable can you put into words
what you saw and whether you think
that the 1500 whatever that number is
americans outside of those gates have a
chance to get to inside the airport by
the deadline of august 31st
let me first say that both the soldiers
and marines who are out there and the
state department civilians are working
tirelessly around the clock
to serve american citizens permanent
residents
special immigrant visa holders and
others who may be eligible and i have
seen them jump and make sure they do
everything they can to rescue american
citizens in harm's way now the gates to
the airport are
unlike anything i've ever seen it is a
throng of individuals oftentimes
thousands deep desperate for a new life
desperate for opportunity mixed in with
that with you know random individuals
who may be desperate but don't have a
document or status you know are
oftentimes american citizens and
soldiers and marines try to pull them
out i mean it is a chaotic uh just
incredibly dangerous and volatile mix
individuals have been trampled to death
i just heard of a two-year-old girl of a
interpreter or work for the us military
who was trampled
we are putting our soldiers and marines
in impossible situations but they are
living up to their code and
we should be proud of how they are with
discipline and responsibility dealing
with this incredibly horrific and
impossible situation congressman the
pentagon didn't know that you were going
uh they said the secretary of defense
would have liked to have consulted with
you before you went and that it's quote
a dangerous intense situation and here's
what your leadership both sides said
about all of this any member that i've
heard that might go i i explained to
them
that i don't think they should
i think it creates a greater risk
you've got enough americans over there
they'll be held hostage they'd make a
point out of a member of congress this
is
deadly serious they do not want members
to go you need the
the approval of your committee chair
in order to do that and we put out the
word to committee chairs there ain't
going to be no planes or this or that
for for people going to the region so
did you complicate things congressman by
the two of you going in the tense and
dynamic situation that the military is
trying to deal with other things besides
two congressmen trying to get a look at
things
yeah let me be very clear brett we were
not planning to go there indeed be
dependent on the u.s military our plan
was entirely independent of that we did
make ourselves known on arrival uh for
situational awareness of the individuals
who were there
but this the the program from the
defense department
from the white house
from the this state department
is frankly
laughable right now they have done
everything they can to obstruct the
situation to deny this reality uh and
frankly to hide facts from the american
people i'll be honest i did not support
the decision to end our operations on
august 31st before i went after talking
with commanders on the ground i trusted
their judgment and i believed it that is
what i want to take back to my fellow
members of congress those are the
stories that i want to tell that aren't
being told of the individuals on the
ground who are committing some of the
most heroic acts i have seen in my life
not to get too into the weeds here but
did you fly in and out privately or was
it military what how did you get there
we did not fly in on u.s military
aircraft like i said our plan was not to
be dependent on anything uh related to
the us government and just the
decisions on behalf of of the president
of the secretary of defense and the
secretary of state to obfuscate here are
more intended to distract from the
underlying issues from the chaos of the
withdrawal than to really tell how we
make sure we write learn the right
lessons support the individuals on the
ground today and keep the promises we've
made to american citizens and those who
have loyally served us in afghanistan
and when you flew in you did so
non-military when you flew out you
didn't fly on military plane and you are
on your way back to the us
we did fly in a military plane on the
way out at the encouragement of
individuals who were there we waited for
a plane that had open seats to make sure
that we didn't take away anything from
individuals who needed it and actually
went several hours out of our way we're
currently in
doha we visited alu dade air base
earlier which is one of the largest
staging operations for this mass
evacuation again to be able to report
what is going on so that congress can
not only exhibit oversight but share and
understand what resources need to be
provided to those who are on the ground
right now so they can continue to save
lives in this chaotic moment it sounds
from your leadership that other
congressmen and women are not going now
the window is closing
and the time is coming to an end if you
had one message to the american people
after what you saw on the ground what
would it be
you have individuals there in kabul who
evacuated the u.s embassy with moments
notice i know soldiers who left behind
their boots they're wearing tennis shoes
right now others who are in the same
uniform they had when they evacuated the
embassy two weeks ago because they
didn't have time to grab their rucksack
they went right into kabul airport into
chaos and pandemonium and tens of
thousands overrunning the runway and
then pivoted to not only negotiating and
having to deal with the taliban as
frankly a security partner rather than
adversary but also execute one of the
most complicated logistical feats and
probably the largest airlift in human
history these people are heroes their
stories need to be told and i am so damn
proud to be an american from what i saw
on the ground in kabul congressman meyer
we appreciate your time
thank you bro hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else